hi i'm tom hardy and i'm andy serkis and
we are doing the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
you really answered those super
thoroughly and really fast well like
well
what is tom hardy
doing now currently i'm working as if
there's a question it's like what am i
working on right now currently i'm doing
a film with gareth evans um for netflix
uh which is a kind of
police thriller
uh
really
uber violent movie
yeah but what are you doing like you
know right now
uh
what is tom hardy's
accent mellifluous i'd say at best as a
collage of places people
things feelings it's irrelevant
if you understand me that's all that
matters
it's a it's a hybrid of of of of wish
fulfillments
and shame i i think i think i'm
bourgeois middle class posh uh middle
class really
and uh and i affect it with all kinds of
interesting variants in order to make
myself seem interesting moving on
what is tom hardy like in a real life
that's a really good question i i've
never you know never come across myself
i might need a bit of a knob today and
um but honestly you know is the day is
long i know that to be absolutely true
hard working very um always diligent
yep
late
often um i'm not always i'm happy i'm
happy i think
good yeah and grateful very grateful to
be alive and and to be privileged
um and to be sat alongside you oh and
here with you and you
what is tom hardy's
in spandex with anyone in particular
with everyone with everyone and everyone
yeah it's such a good look can you
demonstrate some jiu-jitsu no it's
impossible it's impossible to do it
alone show me your grip
this is important if you grip it you
have to put the knuckles on oh really
you go some of those actually quite an
expensive sweater there you go
it doesn't suit you though
okay
okay so how did andy circus
rip off from this side
get into acting how did i get in
because they let me in actually on my
first day of acting i went i got my
equity card which of course he needed in
those days to get into a theater and i
was told that i couldn't enter unless i
had it in my hand so they didn't let me
into the rehearsal room and then it was
a joke and i felt really embarrassed so
you didn't have to have an equity card
no it was a joke how did andy circus
get cast as gollum uh so i
i was asked to to audition for a film
called lord of the rings that was being
made down in new zealand and um i said
surely i wanted a voice for a digital
character and i said surely there must
be like some really good roles in that
movie why do you want me to do a voice
for a digital character and then they
said no it's golem and so i said okay so
i based it on i thought how am i going
to how am i going to do it i'm going to
get into i'm going to basically
impersonate my cat so i'm personally my
cat coughing up furballs and i went
in that way
whoa
ah
that's cool okay so how did andy circus
play king kong how did you play king
kong i played him on set
with
the naomi watts um in a gorilla muscle
suit and i was on top of i do have the
gorilla muscles
and i was on top of uh i was on top of
cherry pickers and cranes and so all
sorts of adjustable height ladders so
that we could be
uh in close proximity to each other or i
could be at the right height and then i
had a thing called congolizer which was
a thing which then projected my voice
through these big speakers so i could
sound like a big gorilla and then i did
and then when all of that was finished
when we did the on-set stuff and we shot
all of naomi's side of things then i
went onto the motion capture stage for
two months and and did all of the kong's
movements so it's a complex effect kind
of blowing my mind i need to work with
you on that kind of stuff okay so how
did andy circus
prepare
for venom too there was nothing that
could prepare me for venom too does tom
hardy
speak french not really i speak really
bad french i can understand no it's
possible i do i do i do understand it
enough to know what you're saying but
why would that question but
because
i may have said
i speak french like i speak i say i ride
horses and i can ski proficiently and
all kinds of things to get work
none of it is true uh does tom hardy
even though i am honest sing people i
don't sing no you do i do not you sing
in this movie
that's true but i'm being paid
but not it's not something that i bring
it's not something that i i i feel the
need to
express myself through the medium of do
you is it easy
but do you so you don't sing in the
shower you don't sing around the house
when you're making sourdough bread yeah
sometimes i think i think today babies
when they were babies just so they get
to know my voice and they could hear my
birth you know whatever baby
but um but now my children say daddy
don't sing because it rains when you see
it
so let's move on
uh does tom hardy
support tottenham i did a documentary uh
about tottenham hotspur but i'm afraid
that if i had to support a team i think
i'd fall into the category of where i
grew up and what he was the closest to
me and that would be brentford does tom
hardy
well i mean
you like dogs i mean what kind of yeah i
love dogs yeah of course i love dogs
yes
as much as if more than humans i think
it's my gateway to liking human beings
yes or understanding at least
okay yeah
that's each to their own right a gateway
drug to humans a gateway of
understanding and caring yeah more
that's amazing of compassion yeah and as
well well i believe
they're less complicated in that aspect
whereas you know human beings are
you know are not
next does
does andy circus sing
no
not really no no not in the shower no
no no
how dull was that question no it wasn't
dull
i mean i mean i wouldn't say like my
wife lorraine scenes all day long she's
just like it's just like a you know if
the house is full of song all day long
so actually i don't get even a word in
edgeways to sing should i even want it
well maybe it's a touchy subject that
does andy
have
one arm
in real life i don't understand that
question um but i guess that's related
to uh
black panther where i played ulysses
claw who
lost an arm
but i wouldn't say our method in the
sense that i was prepared to chop my arm
off
did you have a green black panther i had
a green eye and a green sock because the
arm had to then unpeel as if you like it
so i had a sort of plastic rubber
prosthetic arm over the top which then
then then had lines on it which then
unpeeled to become the sonic weapon but
yes or no
does andy sergius have kids does any
singers have kids does you have kids it
does i does i have three kids uh ruby
sunny and louis uh my daughter's 23 my
son's 21 sunny and louie's 17 all of
whom
have entered into the profession as
young thespians fantastic they all got
their equity cards does andy circus play
a hobbit in return of the
the
king
i mean not strictly speaking although of
course gollum
was
a steward of it so yes i suppose you
could so he was in before he became
before he became um emaciated and and
overpowered by the ring he is a hobbit
he though so yes and that when he's when
he's smeagle
he before he gets transformed into
gollum he is a still hobbit still
hobbits were river hobbits and they
lived by the river gladden does andy
circus ride
motorbikes
no i had a very i'd have i had a
kawasaki 125 when i was about 17 but i
came off it that many times it was just
no it's just not gonna happen
um
yeah now i was constantly
crashing and sliding and trying to but
trying to be evil knievel at the time
probably you know
oh there's more boards
okay there's
four each oh jesus
what
movie
is andy circus i'm gonna go this way
right
directing next were you directing next
that's a good question we've got a whole
bunch of movies that are kind of in
development but what actually comes up
but likely likely to be
animal farm i think is probably the next
orwell's animal farm uh that is that is
actually currently in the early works of
being developed and to a movie what does
andy circus do
for fun
what that we can talk about here
what do you feel comfortable
i'm massively into um climbing i'm a big
very passionate mountaineer i love being
in the mountains a door being in the
mountains in fact the you know i was in
the mountains last week what did andy
serkis
play
in star wars people know that so why is
that because people googled us like
because they didn't recognize you
clearly maybe my guess would be
all right if i say this
you might just give you a clue have you
felt it
that was a line from star wars in which
i played supreme leader snoke the
character that no one knows where he
came from where he's going to or what he
is
or whatever anything about him because
he's so mysterious including myself what
is andy circus
work
what is andy circus's workout routine
okay i like cycling i like uh as i say
climbing and i do
occasional and and i like walking i like
i actually like walking every day very
fast around the heath
are you being investigated
okay so what uh
inspire what inspires andy circa
that's hard tom hardy oh
majorly uh woody harrison naomi harris
kandinsky
francis bacon um
miles davis john coltrane
uh nina simone um
they're beautiful inspirations man
i mean
me with standing up
how did tom hardy become an actor yeah i
think i was about 19 20 19 20 and it was
when we were auditioning for drama
schools and i didn't get in
i was like no i i need to do that it's
fomo
well there's nothing else i can do
nothing it's an unusual thing to go into
really um to sort of invested
everything on something that was
unlikely to work
but there you go
how did
tom hardy
fight himself in legend now i didn't
fight myself absolutely i fought with
jacob tamuri who's um obviously um
a good friend of mine and a brilliant
stunt man and we've been working since
few years together and we uh cobbled
that together with justin spencer in a
couple of days and it took us two days
to shoot and um it was really good fun
actually and it was over jake's shoulder
on to me and then over jake's shoulder
onto me as he swapped from running to
reggie as well with me
here we go
how did tom hardy train for venom uh i
had two knee surgeries and sat around
didn't i
but um
like yeah i had two meniscus and it was
just before literally not long before
shooting it was unbelievable i don't
know how you did that we'll just have to
do it you know i toured a meniscus on
the first venom
uh because i wore boxing boots because
it looked so cool and i was like oh they
look really good and i really think that
would be great for the character and
they were ended but they've got no
cushion in them so you're running around
on the concrete i just i'm old enough to
cause damage quick and that was it uh
and then i had the meniscus went in jiu
jitsu and then i couldn't get
if i bent down i couldn't stand up again
because they all locked and stuff i was
rubbish sorry i had the operation really
quick
thinking just a shave on both but it was
i had two back-to-back eight weeks
before i know we started filming and
then so that the fighting was a little
bit
how
did tom hardy do the blame voice that
was actually
really cool choice that chris made chris
nolan
bain quintessentially is uh latinx in
many
origin of a character and i am not so i
looked at the uh
the concept of latin and found a
character a gentleman called a gentleman
a man called bartley gorman who's a
romani gypsy
and the king of the gypsies inverted
commas and a bare knuckle fighter
and a boxer and uh he said would i go
into a ring with a man and we want to
wipe me off the fish of the earth and he
wants to kill me and i was like oh this
is great and then i i showed chris i
said chris we can either
go down a
sort of arch darth vader kind of route
and you know straight you know just
neutral toned villain voice
or we could try this and this i've been
thinking of just in case we you know we
we you know we've got to consider the
roots and origins of the of the bane but
we could get laughed out the part with
it it might be something that we regret
but it's your choice ultimately because
no i think we'll go with it
that was that well we played with it and
made a bit more florid and uh
and now people love it
is andy circus
actually is that any circus america well
it's a it's a little-known secret that
i'm not known
is andy circus in venom be honest
be honest
okay
no
actually do you know what
there is a moment
where yeah
do you remember at the breakfast table
where where where where venom is tapping
eddie brock on the shoulder yes
and you said can you be the tendril of
venom yes
cheer up buddy i kind of am in the movie
you are cheering up buddy cheer up buddy
is it andy circus
in game of thrones
look anybody who watches game of thrones
will clearly know that i'm not in it but
are you in it
i'm invested in it
but definitely not in it is andy circus
married very definitely yeah
yes uh been together with lorraine for
30 years now
30 long very happy we've never argued
once uh years and we have three children
rupees honey and louis and uh yeah yeah
we sort of still rub along together
things things are all right you know
hanging in there
all right well this is going to be uh
this is dangerous now this is going into
dangerous territory did tom hardy
actually eat a live lobster several what
wow
did you i think it's only fair isn't it
you know like once i did one in the tank
that i finished the rest of them off
because they they witnessed
and they're a higher being as well
because they no i didn't eat any of them
they were um
it's a high sentient being apparently
because it lives off and it eats as
a bottom feeder and it can subsist on
on what people don't need you know i
mean
a lobster that's very interesting were
there not rules in the union against
lobsters
there's no union for lobsters
did tom hardy
ad-lib peaky blind lettuce add libyan
peaky blinders i i i guess yeah well to
be honest steve knight is such an
awesome writer of dialogue that um
there is there is no reason to add live
in peaky blinders at all and he always
gives me a good 10-page scene whenever i
turn up a day so
i can't lie i do ad-lib as well i like
to go off that
exactly on the adr stage i've noticed i
do like to add limb yeah but i'm based
off a solid screen
to get all of steve knight's work in
there because that's what should be in
there and it's awesome but it's just so
good i just like to go off what's next
next
is did tom hardy
actually fly a plane in dunkirk
uh like um like douglas barda kind of
like old school yeah or in the film in
in the film
because i wasn't on the day i didn't
actually fly a plane back in in the
second world war oh you didn't no um but
in the film in the film
i didn't actually fly a pain in the film
either but everything um that i shot was
shot in a sort of cockpit seat
um
hanging over a cliff that's amazing you
can see the scene
um
did tom hardy
voice bane in south park no i didn't no
i didn't but i'm glad that somebody did
if they did did they have they they must
have done that's awesome that's cool
isn't it it's great to have your
character immortalized in such a fine
piece of animation well we're reminded
that i am just a
collage and fragment of
insecurities and neurosis but we've
established that you are deeply honest
so that's what the root of everything
that's important yeah that's true and
you like to climb out exactly exactly
nothing profound in that it's been a
pleasure completely thank you for
watching goodbye